ja und plötzlich krieg viele von uns
erinnern sich an die invasion und
annektierung der krim 2014 droht jetzt
ein neuer krieg wladimir putin hat fast
100.000 soldaten an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze postiert
das gab es noch nie dass es brenzlig das
kann eskalieren ja und das ist ganz nah
an europa was also tun wie soll die
politik reagieren wie soll deutschland
reagieren rolf mützenich zum beispiel
von der spd fordert jetzt von europa und
russland sich nicht
gegenseitig zu drohen ob diese
forderungen angemessen ist was sagt uns
einer der dort schon vor ort war bild
vize paul ronzheimer jetzt bei uns hier
im studio
ein kommentar ich empfinde das als
absoluten skandal dass der fraktionschef
der kanzlerpartei allen ernstes davon
spricht dass man gegenseitig aufhören
müsse zu drohen man muss sich das einmal
bildlich vorstellen da sind über 100000
truppen an der grenze zwischen russland
und der ukraine ich war selbst ganz
häufig vor ort die menschen leiden dort
die haben täglich kriegsangst und jetzt
geht es darum dass möglicherweise putin
weitere truppen rein schickt weitere
teile der ukraine an für sich einnimmt
weil er sagt das ist unser
sowjetimperiums und dass dann die partei
die momentan den kanzler stellen eine
million auf holz und rolf mützenich der
fraktionschef nicht sehen will werde
aggressors das ist nämlich nur wladimir
putin da gibt es die nato da gibt es die
europäische union aber die haben
russland nicht gedroht und die spd tut
wieder so als gäbe es da ein
gegenseitiges hin und her nein das gibt
es nicht es gibt nur einen aggressor und
der heißt wladimir putin und ich
empfinde das wirklich als problematisch
ich habe 2014 15 16 all die jahre aus
dieser kriegsregion berichtet und habe
gesehen was passiert ist mit den
russischen truppen damals auf der krim
als sie eingeflogen kann das ganze land
übernommen haben und diese angst die es
dort gibt ich spreche dort mit freunden
die menschen haben wahnsinnige angst vor
einer invasion dass weitere russische
truppen einmarschieren könnten und dass
dann die kanzlerpartei nicht
ausschließlich auf der seite der ukraine
steht sondern von gegenseitigen
drohungen spricht rolf mützenich an
einem paralleluniversum offenbar lebt
empfinde ich als skandalös wir sprechen
gleich mit vitali klitschko auch darüber
der bürgermeister von kiew der großen
box legende die jeder in deutschland
kennt wollen aber zunächst mal hören was
die neue außenministerin annalena
baerbock sagte die kaum hat sie ihr amt
begonnen in die erste große richtig
große gefährliche krise hinein kommen
könnte wir haben mal kurz rein
die russische truppen entwicklung nach
der ukraine geht uns alle an nicht nur
im hinblick auf die ukraine sondern auch
im hinblick auf unsere sicherheit in
europa die nato hat eine klare botschaft
gesetzt ich unterstreiche nachdrücklich
dass die neue regierung diesen kurs
unterstützen
das commitment und wird live zu hören
stritzel der die außenministerin
annalena baerbock auf ihren ersten
auslandsreisen begleitet gerade in
schweden ist und von dort uns jetzt live
zugeschaltet jörn welche motive hat
annalena baerbock
wenn sie jetzt so deutliche worte
spricht geht es da wirklich nur um die
kräne oder ist er auch das projekt nord
stream 2 im hintergrund spielt das eine
rolle dass sie ja dass die grünen
ablehnen aber natürlich ein
herzensprojekt von wladimir putin ist
ich glaube dass das kann man gar nicht
wenn also tatsächlich dass im fall max
grimm zweiter beides die hat ja auch
betont
bei einem
spiel zwei
nicht so dazu gilt es mit dem
europäischen gesetzen zu lenken hat
damit im prinzip einfacher weise muss
man sagen die weihnacht brüssel gegeben
wenn die kommission dass dort überprüfen
und insofern kann sie dann ein bisschen
eleganten sich spalten der
aus dem weg hin zum einen ist das auch
das hat's ja auch ein lademeister in
diesen zwei natürlich unmittelbar zu
erleben um auch damit zu tun dass ich
grandios
die staaten an der ostflanke der garten
das richtig ausgesprochen wird ruhig für
banken und vladimir putin früchten
solches energiepreis ball zu werden sie
lebt wie erlebst du annalena baerbock
jetzt sie ist erst wenige tage im amt
und dann schon diese große krise du bist
ganz nah an mir dran
also sie wirklich fröhlich selbstbewusst
und machte ich den eindruck es in diesem
jahr konzessionen machen wir den
koalitionspartner gegen ihn
angesprochen die
unsägliche äußerung von rund zehn jahre
wahrscheinlich eine einzelmeinung in der
spd es zb auch das muss dann darauf
hätten der bundesregierung gar nicht
dass der spd der sich vor wenigen tagen
auch noch mal zu wort gemeldet hat und
ähnlich wie die nützen nicht ebenfalls
darauf verwiesen hat dass die dass der
westen seine drohungen einstellen müsse
drohungen dies aber sie sind eben nicht
die tatsächlich das ist keine ein
wechselseitiges hochschaukeln oder
dergleichen und dann so kann glaube ich
ja mach zumindest an einem berg und auch
andere polizei
was würden sie da der spd so weit
entgegenkommen das dass man da
mit
wem redet auf meine frage
sie haben aber wie nimmst du das war
also das ist ja tatsächlich möglicher
koalitionskrach herkommen könnte nämlich
auf der einen seite die grünen die sehr
auf menschenrechte auf das was in der
ukraine passiert die für nord gegen nord
stream sind und die spd die immer für
dialog und für jahr aussprache mit
russland ist wie sind die zwischentöne
da wenn man annalena baerbock darauf
anspielt hat sie sorge dass ich am ende
das kanzleramt durchsetzt und sie
sozusagen nur von der seite flankieren
kann
also den eindruck habe ich nicht das ist
jetzt das kanzleramt
seine
[Applaus]
mannschaft sozusagen nicht klar zu
machen dass außen spielt nicht mit
anstand gemacht werde und das ist
sozusagen wir richten die kompetenz des
kanzlers sagen sich dann auch auf die
aussenpolitiker speck allerdings
nicht dass das bei den bei den grünen
der einfach denkt dass man muss man dann
zurück sprechen würde hinter dem leben
was man ja auch im koalitionsvertrag
beschlossen hat er ist bei uns im 2
beispielsweise speziell hinter den
ausflug zum beispiel darauf verwiesen
dass energiepolitische projekten
deutschland eben auch mit der
europäischen
energiesicherheit
beispiel sagen und insofern nicht
bei den beiden kleinen politischen
partner am besten das becken
zunehmende spannungen mit russland
dann erleben wir eine aufrüstung wieso
nie gesehen haben in china auch neue
langstreckenraketen die außenministerin
beginnt ihren job in einer gefährlichen
zeit wie sind ihre positionen auch
gegenüber china beispielsweise
auch deutlich deutlich andere also
deutlich
provozierter als man das bisher aus dem
kanzleramt
die menschenrechtslage eine weitaus
deutlichere rolle
generell muss man sagen als das eben in
der spd und union getan hat also da wird
er wird klar darauf bei diesem welche
menschenrecht verletzt habe ich
navigierten das scheint mir schon
wirklich nur
bis dahin sagt sondern ein wechselndes
absolut
also auch die die tatsache dass zum
beispiel die wahren experten im
koalitionsvertrag erwähnt wurde darüber
lange gerungen wurde wo ich gehört habe
aus dem parkplatz beim marschieren spd
seite sehr lange dagegen wurde das so
explizit erwähnt wurde das zeigen auch
die beiden kleineren koalitionspartners
nicht gewillt sind diesen kurs gegenüber
diesem beschwichtigen muss zum beispiel
auch wirklich durch mitarbeiter mit
und da ist leider die verbindung weg
vielen dankbaren stütze für diese
eindrücke aus stockholm und japan lass
uns noch mal schnell auf die ukraine
schauen wie dramatisch ist es wirklich
im du hast eben auch schon von den
ängsten der menschen dort gesprochen ich
meine jetzt stehen 100.000 soldaten
wollen das land ein was macht das mit
den menschen dort ich kenne vitali
klitschko seit über zehn jahren und habe
immer wieder kontakt mit ihm einmal in
der woche fast und für mich so
sinnbildlich für das was in den menschen
vorgeht war ein anruf von ein paar tagen
als ich mit ihm telefoniert habe und er
sagt ich bin gerade aufgewacht ich hatte
einen alptraum ich dachte die russischen
soldaten stehen schon vor der tür also
psychologisch muss man sagen ist es für
die ukraine wirklich dramatisch und
klitschko sagte zu mir ebenfalls es ist
so damals vor der invasion auf der krim
das konnte sich auch niemand vorstellen
dass das tatsächlich passieren würde er
sagte wenn man mir 2012 11 gesagt hätte
irgendwann übernehmen russische soldaten
es gibt eine invasion dann hätten die
mich für verrückt erklärt dass sehr
viele menschen glauben dass putin zu
allem bereit ist und sie sind enttäuscht
davon dass in deutschland viele das
nicht wahrnehmen wollen und sagen na ja
das hat ja irgendwie alte zeiten history
russland ukraine war ja immer eng nei
das ist ein ganz ganz großer unterschied
seit der moderne revolution und auch
schon davor hat die europäische in
diesem land so massiv zugenommen die
möchten nicht mehr verbunden werden mit
der alten sowjet zeit die möchten in
eine moderne demokratische europäische
zukunft und das ist ihre große angst
dass putin ihn das kaputt machen will
dass er in die ukraine einmarschiert und
das für immer beenden könnte yonath
putin gelernt er kann im grunde machen
was er will es wird keine schafe
gegenreaktion geben und man realistisch
betrachtet selbst wenn er in die ost
ukraine einmarschieren würde würde die
nato kein bündnisfall die ukraine ist
nicht in der nato erklären und
amerikaner oder auch deutsche würden
keine truppen schicken genauso ist es
thomas und das verzweifelt die menschen
diese der wunsch zur nato zu gehören
dann gibt es noch keine sehr sehr lange
schon der wird nicht erfüllt werden weil
man immer gesagt hat man darf putin
nicht provozieren wenn man sozusagen dem
willen der lokalen nachgeben würde und
sagen wir okay hier dürften die nato
dann wäre das eine riesige provokation
aber du sprichst die militärische
dimension an und da hätte die ukraine
gar keine chance gegen russische truppen
das militär in russland ist der ukraine
maximal überlegen natürlich hat sich die
ukrainische armee weiter entwickelten im
vergangenen jahr nachdem sie 2014 diese
invasion lebt haben aber wenn russlands
truppen kommen dann könnte das eine
frage von tagen wochen sein und die
ukraine ist in der kontrolle russlands
was nicht bedeutet dass die menschen zu
russland gehören wollen das heißt die
sind eigentlich machtlos machtlos will
ich nicht sagen das war ein großer preis
den potenzial russische soldaten würden
sterben die frage ist wie das dann auch
in russland ankommt und natürlich wäre
es so dass der europäischen union oder
den usa nichts anderes übrigbleibt wenn
sich schon keine truppen schicken wenn
sie es schon nicht schaffen ein
europäisieren das land zu verteidigen
dass sie dann zumindest schärfere
sanktionen oder sehr scharfe sanktionen
ins gespräch bringen beziehungsweise
umsetzen und da geht es dann zum
beispiel um die frage ob man russland
komplett ausschaltet aus der bank
transferunion swat heißt das was dann
wirtschaftliche riesenprobleme bringen
könnte für russland paul du hast es
gesagt und hilf uns regelmäßig mit
vitali klitschko wir wollten gerade auch
mit ihm sprechen er musste kurzfristig
absagen auch ein zeichen dafür was ihm
dort jetzt durch den kopf geht wenn
vielleicht letzte frage an dich er hat
gesagt wenn es soweit ist werde er
kämpfen was bedeutet das
das bedeutet dass vitali klitschko ein
wahnsinniger ukrainischer patriot ist
und er ist jemand der seine militär
familie kommt besonders spannend
insofern auch als das sein vater
russischer herkunft ist und die mutter
ukrainerin und erst einer militär
familie kommt der vater ist damals in
tschernobyl unglück geflogen hat
helikopter einsätze geflogen als das
atomkraftwerkes bild ist er hatte immer
eine wahnsinnige bindung zu russland und
er sagt wenn es so weit kommen sollte
wenn russische truppen wieder in die
ukraine einmarschieren dann ist er
bereit als er da zu kämpfen und vitali
klitschko ist jemand dem kann man sein
wort abnehmen ich glaube er wird das tun
letzte frage wie sehr betrifft uns diese
krise auch hier in deutschland müssen
wir angst haben wir müssen angst haben
davor dass russland sich weiter ausdehnt
dass russland wenn sie in die ukraine
einmarschieren sehr viel näher an
deutschland werden wir müssen sorge
dafür haben dass russland zb das gas
einsetzt um uns zu erpressen um uns zu
sagen nein ihr dürft menschen in der
ukraine nicht helfen weil sonst wird
euer gas teurer also man kann nur immer
wieder sagen all das was dort passiert
da kann man sagen die ukraine wäre erst
der erste schritt was ist dann das
nächste kommt der liter und kommt dann
polen und dann wäre man an der deutschen
grenze